I dunno about the national football
league and I know this the NFL for years
has wanted to get from 16 regular season
games to 18 regular season games and the
NFL realizes 18 won't be happening so
the compromise 17 games that was
something at Packard CEO Mark Murphy
advocated in July and it is taking root
and it makes sense you would have a true
home games a true road games and one
neutral site game per team per year that
would be an inventory Chris of 16 games
that can be played anywhere like England
or elsewhere like Australia if they
wanted to try to work that out so it
looks like it's moving in that direction
for the first time the Commissioner
addressed that there are indeed talks
occurring along those lines here's what
he had to say when he was asked that
specific question as to whether or not
they are negotiating with the Players
Association on a 17 game season we've
had very fruitful discussions on it
discussing the positive [ __ ] the
changes of the game that we've made over
the last 10 years which I think are
really important as it relates to the
safety of the game and how we're
preparing and practicing and training
our our players and I think those
changes have made a significant impact
in a positive way and so that is
something that we'll continue to discuss
it was just a matter of time Chris
before someone from the league linked
the idea that they have made dramatic
changes to the rules to make the game
safer over the last 10 years so now that
the game is safer let's play more games
right it's easier to justify expanding
the season if you can say there were
health and safety issues that we've
addressed with rule changes that have
evolved and and really it's been
revolutionary when you consider what's
happened over the last 10 years versus
what happened over the first 90 years
but that's what they're trying to do
that's how they're trying to sell it and
and I feel like it's something that that
is going to happen whether yes everyone
is on board with it I don't think all
the owners are on board with it but I
think it's gonna happen because they
understand the value of having another
weekend of regular-season games and
they'll shrink the preseason down to
three games or two games to balance it
out it seems inevitable and I'm sure you
know the money and I think is gotten
with you I think the money
gonna be too great for for all parties
involved to wear the you know this what
this will get done at some point now let
me ask you this are you surprised that
you know I always thought it was gonna
be a teen game so I thought I was gonna
have like an even number are they like
laying in the weeds and telling us 17 to
get a feel engage for that I mean why do
you think 17 I was just surprised by
that know the players have made it clear
they're not interested in 18 so this is
the next best thing and I think that
enough of the owners don't want a teen
that 17s a compromise not just with the
players it's a compromise with the
owners and it's a step toward 18 right
maybe you get to 18 by first going to 17
yeah and here's the other thing here's
here's here's to me a fascinating
wrinkle to all of this I don't know when
they would move to 17 games Goodell made
it clear that the season would continue
to start the weekend after Labor Day
okay that's fine what that does is it
pushes everything back a week it pushes
the Super Bowl ultimately back a week
the next five Super Bowls have firm
dates not either-or weekend's firm dates
and it's not just well we'll use the
stadium next Sunday instead of this
Sunday there's a lot more logistically
that goes into a Super Bowl you need a
Convention Center for the entire week
yeah you need thousands of hotel rooms
for the entire week especially as the
weekend approaches you can't just say oh
well it's gonna be February 9th instead
of February 2nd you need at least
multiple years to plan for it in advance
and it may not even be possible now so
there's a chance that we're gonna have
one or more Super Bowls where Conference
championship weekend and then go right
and then no dead week now I don't know
when they would do the the Pro Bowl
maybe they'd have to play the Pro Bowl
the week after the Super Bowl those
years yeah but that may be a necessity
because I think if it comes down to it
and they get the clearance to go 17
they're going 17 and they'll work out
all the other stuff on the backend yeah
you're probably right it's interesting I
did not think about that aspect of it I
don't like that aspect of it as far as
when the team only has one week to
prepare for the Super Bowl
I want teams to be at their healthiest
at their best for the Super Bowl
I want the coaches to have the best
creative game plans available so we can
see the best entertainment to me that
that's what it's all about you know you
know the last time that there was only
one week between conference
every chip supermom I thought it was the
Raiders in the Bucs maybe but am I wrong
what is it
Rams Patriots Reb is an entertaining
game you're right that was very yeah
that was you're right all right we're
gonna take a break you're wrong you're
right after this I think you're wrong
I'm gonna look it up yep
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports